lieber genosse poweleit du hast geholfen
eine neue ordnung einzurichten
in der das geld nicht alle dinge regelt
ein paar jahren hat einen roman den
deutschen buchpreis geworden und das
passiert jedes jahr aber aktivitäten
jedes jahr passiert ist dass dieser
roman dann auch verfilmt wird das ist
mein leben aber so was jetzt gibt es
eine verfilmung eines buchpreisträger
die tatsächlich auch ins kino kommt
nämlich in ruse roman in zeiten des
abnehmenden lichts und darin jedes um
den untergang der ddr zusätzliche
politische lage ein problem ist dass das
problem das problem ist natürlich für
alle leute brennen interessant die sich
noch an 1989 erinnern
weil man dort dann etwas über die
stimmung in der ddr gerade auch unter
den eliten denjenigen die eigentlich
ziemlich treu zum system stehen erfährt
was dann in dieser intensität ganz
selten im kino vorgeführt wird vor allem
ohne jede schwarz-weiß-malerei
verbringen die chance gorbatschow einen
der kandidaten welche hinter sich nicht
nachzudenken
in gewisser weise hat der film etwas
ganz anderes gemacht als rookie in
seinem buch den ruge hat eine große
familiengeschichte erzählt die in
rückblenden bis in die 40er jahre zurück
führte
und wiederum auch weit über den
untergang der ddr hinaus griff nämlich
bis in die unmittelbare gegenwart und
das hat der film sich weitgehend gespart
das spielt alles im herbst 1982 an einem
einzigen tag
die busse der großteil der 100 minuten
dreht sich um den geburtstag des
familienpatriarchen der von bruno ganz
ganz großartig gespielt wird und so
gesehen ist ein roman der jahrzehnte
erzählt auf einen tag reduziert worden
es gibt keine blumen die habe ich zu
einem stillen sehr gemocht habe an die
einbeziehung der russische
familienmitglieder
es gibt immer wieder russische dialog
was sagen die natürlich untertitel
sorgen sind chinesen
wenn man dann bedenkt dass mit wolfgang
kohlhaase ein wirklicher veteran des
ostdeutschen aber auch mittlerweile
insgesamt deutschen kinos das drehbuch
verfasst hat jetzt noch mal zu sehen wie
er in gewisser weise mit dieser adaption
auch noch mal zurück fliegt das ist
schon im höchsten maße faszinierend denn
viele faszinierendere dialoge wiederum
hat wolfgang kohlhaase fragt im
deutschen kino kaum jemand bringt das
gemüse bewegung das ganz klar dass bruno
ganz das zentrum dieses films darstellt
und es macht den mensch viel spaß beim
spielen zuzusehen
aber darüber hinaus kommen all diese
rollen neben bruno ganz nicht so richtig
zur geltung
die schwierigkeit scheint mir bei diesem
film zu sein dass ein großer ensemble
film suggeriert wird durch die besetzung
dass er im endeffekt sich doch alles auf
den patriarchen konzentriert der
minister der deutschen demokratischen
republik verließ wilhelm den sternen der
völkerfreundschaft gold im großen und
ganzen ist dann doch ein konventioneller
film geworden zu einem buch was nicht
konventionelles und dementsprechend hat
es meine erwartungen doch eher
enttäuscht wie dieser roman verfilmt
worden ist
[Applaus]